[Applaus]
[Musik]
ratet mal welches land der größte film
produzent der welt ist die meisten von
euch werden wahrscheinlich total falsch
liegen wenn das land in dem die meisten
produziert werden ist indien nah beim
stichwort bollywood hat es bei manchen
vielleicht gefunkt aber lass mich noch
eine zweite frage stellen welches land
denkt ihr ist der zweitgrößte
filmproduzent nach indien jetzt wagt ihr
wohl noch mehr daneben als beim ersten
mal
die antwort lautet nämlich nigeria
[Musik]
ja das hat sich ja fast niemand richtig
erraten
im sogenannten non food werden vielmehr
stellen und pro jahr gedreht als er mit
viel bekannteren politik das aber weiß
natürlich so gut wie niemand denn afrika
ist der vergessene kontinent über die
amerikanische politik und wirtschaft
könnt ihr aus deutschsprachigen
zeitungen oder nachrichtensendungen so
gut wie gar nichts erfahren wobei sich
dieses schweigen nicht nur auf
deutschsprachige medien beschränkt
sondern auf alle außerhalb afrikas
selbst
[Musik]
und deshalb kann man behaupten dass die
afrikaner zurzeit zeuge eines absolut
stillen wunders werden bis in die 2000er
jahre schien diese region verlegt dem
untergang geweiht zu sein aber seit
beginn des neuen jahrhunderts hat sich
das einkommen der einwohner afrikas
verdreifacht länder wie äthiopien
wachsen jahr für jahr mit einer rate von
zehn prozent
[Musik]
und ich weiß was du mir jetzt entgegnen
sie ist kommt schon mag die sind doch
nur statistiken an den lebensumständen
der meisten menschen dort ändert sich
doch nichts oder
nun ja es sieht folgendermaßen aus wenn
er jetzt überall so was wie blitzende
wolkenkratzer und kolonnen nagelneuer
bmw es auf den straßen von nairobi
erwartet dann ja werdet ihr wohl
enttäuscht sein
so weit sind sie noch nicht tatsächlich
gibt es auf diesem kontinent noch immer
regionen in denen extreme armut herrscht
dies ist zb in der volksrepublik kongo
und der zentralafrikanischen republik
der fall aber in anderen regionen geht
es rasant aufwärts zb wurden in der
äthiopischen hauptstadt addis abeba in
letzter zeit ein paar supermärkte
eröffnet das mag jetzt äußerst trivial
vorkommen aber es handelt sich um einen
riesenschritt wenn man bedenkt dass
dieses land von nur 30 jahren schauplatz
einer der schlimmsten hungersnöte der
weltgeschichte war das ist aber noch
lange nicht alles langsam kann man
beobachten dass afrikanische unternehmen
international expandieren zum beispiel
die äthiopischen fluggesellschaften oder
mp sei eine zahlungs plattform für
mobiltelefone
[Musik]
jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht aus
welchem grund wächst afrika auf einmal
auf solch wundersame weise welches neue
phänomen auf diesem kontinent hat zu
dieser positiven entwicklung geführt die
antwort lautet ganz klar frieden denn
die allererste voraussetzungen für die
entwicklung eines landes ist dass es
keine kriege
danach können wir gerne über politische
systeme steuerpolitik oder was auch
immer debattieren eine gesellschaft die
inmitten eines schlachtfeldes leben muss
kann kaum gedeihen aber jetzt fangen an
sich zu ändern nicht wahr
auf jeden fall jahrzehntelang war afrika
wirklich ein kontinent voller gewalt
unabhängigkeitskriege stammeskonflikte
und sogar folter mord heute hat die zahl
der konflikte jedoch erheblich
abgenommen
im jahr 1990 starben durchschnittlich 45
von 100.000 afrikaner durch kriegerische
auseinandersetzungen heute ist diese
zahl auf 800.000 gesunken und natürlich
war diese entwicklung eine enorme hilfe
für ein aufblühen des handels und
ausländische investitionen insbesondere
mit und aus china
nichtsdestotrotz hat afrika noch eine
menge arbeit vor sich es ist noch weit
davon entfernt zum wohlhabenden teil der
erde gezählt werden können es muss jetzt
den nächsten schritt gehen und welcher
ist das nun da wäre die
industrialisierung bis lang ist und
bleibt afrika einen erster linie
ländlich geprägter kontinent bisher hat
afrika kaum etwas anderes anbieten als
rohstoff und es ist äußerst schwierig
eine moderne und komplexe
volkswirtschaft allein auf der grundlage
von landwirtschaft und bergbau
aufzubauen
dies ist also der kontext in den dann
folgenden meldung besteht
größte freihandelsvertrag seit fast
einem vierteljahrhundert soll afrika zu
einem binnenmarkt machen ja das hast du
richtig gehört das ziel dieses vertrags
ist es eine afrikanische version des
europäischen binnenmarktes zu schaffen
der der keim für das war was wir heute
als europäische union kennen und am 30
mai 2009 10 ist dieser vertrag
tatsächlich wirklichkeit geworden wir
sprechen hier von einer zahl von 52
unterzeichner ländern nur wenige
afrikanische länder wie nigeria und
eritrea haben sich den beitritt zur
sogenannten hfc fta oder einfach cfk
verweigert also lautet die frage jetzt
hat dieser vertrag wirklich das zeug
dazu das volle potenzial der
afrikanischen wirtschaft zu entfalten
und diesem vollends im turbo modus auf
den wachstumspfad zu schicken oder geht
es dabei doch nur wieder um einen haufen
netter worte kann ein solches
freihandelsabkommen das leben in afrika
wirklich gewässern und warum will
ausgerechnet nigeria welches das land
mit der größten afrikanischen wirtschaft
ist es nicht unterzeichnen heute werden
wir alle diese fragen beantworten aber
vorher wollen wir noch einen blick
zurück in die geschichte werfen
kein markt keine industrie wenn wir über
afrika sprechen sollten wir eines nicht
vergessen
55 länder und 1,3 milliarden menschen
sollten daher nicht über afrika einfach
so reden als handle es sich um ein land
andererseits gibt es eine sache welche
die meisten afrikanischen länder
gemeinsam haben ihre koloniale
vergangenheit die meisten dieser
nationen sind seit weniger als 50 jahren
unabhängig und glaubt mir
sie unterhalten noch immer enge
beziehungen zu ihren früheren
kolonialmächten von denen sie einst
besetzt waren
in vielerlei hinsicht ist die idee einer
wirklichen unabhängigkeit für diese
länder eine illusion schaut den normalen
ländern ist es so dass die
haupthandelspartner die nachbarländer
sind amerika handelt mit mexiko und
kanada frankreich mit deutschland
deutschland mit den niederlanden aber in
afrikanischen ländern läuft es in dieser
hinsicht ganz anders die elfenbeinküste
zum beispiel grenzt an ghana und liberia
aber welche
kinder sind die haupthandelspartner der
elfenbeinküste nein es wird nicht ihre
nachbarn ihre haupthandelspartner sind
die niederlande und frankreich welches
überraschender weise der ehemalige
kolonialherr der elfenbeinküste ist gut
so langsam fängt dieser trend an sich zu
drehen aber ganz und gar nicht so wie
man es vielleicht erwarten würde wenn
ihr visual politik schon länger schaut
das tier bereits dass china in den
letzten jahren sein einfluss in afrika
stark forciert aber nicht nur die
ostasiaten spielen hier eine rolle
seht euch mal folgende meldung kommende
verlangsamung des chinesischen wachstums
öffnet die türen für eine ausweitung des
afrikanischen handels mit indien aber
nicht nur das in den letzten 15 jahren
hat sich der handel afrikas mit anderen
ländern wie der türkei und indonesien
verdreifacht heute machen die geschäfte
mit asien 45% des afrikanischen
außenhandels aus europa liegt bei 31
prozent
wie ihr sehen könnt bleibt danach also
nur ein kleiner prozentsatz für den
innerafrikanischen handel und ja ich
weiß was sie jetzt denken und leben wir
nicht im zeitalter der grenzenlosen
globalisierung der weltwirtschaft warum
sollte ein so reger handel mit asien und
europa zu afrika ein problem darstellen
nun leider stellt dies ein äußerst
großes problem dar
denkt einfach mal kurz nach welche waren
kauft europa oder asien aus afrika ja
ihr habt es erraten rohstoffe wie öl gas
gold oder uran
mit anderen worten alles außer
fertigprodukten und dafür gibt es einen
grund sehen sie uns ein beispiel an
[Musik]
die honda motorcycle company wurde 2017
gegründet sie stellt preiswerte
motorräder her würdet ihr so ein produkt
kaufen wahrscheinlich nicht denn ihre
motorräder sind wieder einer suzuki noch
einer 100 gewachsen kein asiatischer
oder europäischer konsument würde sich
also für ein romantisches modell
entscheiden wenn daneben auch ein
japanisches oder amerikanisches zu
erstehen ist wo also könnten ruandische
motorräder käufer finden natürlich in
anderen afrikanischen ländern
tatsächlich afrika eine großartige
absatzmarkt für diese produkte weil es
dort fast keine konkurrenz gibt denn
wenn du zum beispiel im kongo lebt dann
viel glück bei der suche nach einer bmw
fachwerkstatt doch was für dich
vielleicht bedeuten kann ist wird diese
rollen und ein großes glück denn vor
ihnen liegt ein riesiger ozean
vollkommene jungfräulicher absatzmärkte
voller chancen
[Musik]
dies erklärt dann auch warum der trotz
geringen außenhandels wurde der
afrikanischen länder untereinander
der größte teil dieses handels mit
industriegütern mit anderen worten wenn
afrika industrie haben will muss es mehr
handel untereinander treiben
gut dann haben wir ja schon die lösung
wo also liegt das problem nun die krux
dabei ist dass die dinge in afrika nie
einfach sind und handel schwieriger als
alles andere es gibt einen haufen zölle
und bürokratie welche es lokalen
unternehmen fast unmöglich machen
grenzüberschreitend zu handeln wenn man
ein romantisches motorrad im
benachbarten kongo schicken möchte
werden zunächst einmal zollgebühren von
circa 20 prozent des kreises fällig aber
diese zölle sind nur die spitze des
eisbergs von handelshemmnissen man muss
nämlich auch die zöllner bestechen wenn
man nicht will dass die ware dort
monatelang auf abfertigung
[Musik]
hinzu kommt sicherheitsprobleme banken
und volos die in vielen regionen noch
immer präsent sind
vergesst nicht dass sich vor wenigen
jahren viele dieser länder gegenseitig
noch die bürger abgeschlachtet haben
auch hier gilt ein motorrad hersteller
in ronda kann mit einem so kleinen und
armen markt die dem heimischen kaum
überlegen wenn er überleben möchte muss
er ins ausland expandieren
mit anderen worten protektionismus macht
es afrika fast unmöglich sich zu
entwickeln
jetzt passt aber bitte gut auf denn
genau das könnte sich bald ändern
[Musik]
die afrikanische union blood diamond ist
ein hollywood film in dem es darum geht
wie es dazu kommen kann dass sich
menschen legen ein paar winzige
mineralien gegenseitig umbringen wollen
die schlussfolgerung dieses films ist
dass der westen sich in afrika film
nichts anderes interessiert als
rohstoffe in dieser situation mögen
viele denken dass die menschen afrika
ist einfach nicht in der lage sind sich
mal selbst zusammenzureißen und es ohne
die helfende hand des westens einfach
nicht gehen wird aber hier seid ihr bei
visual politik und ist natürlich dass
wir in das denken
[Musik]
afrikas geschichte wurde von anderen
geschrieben
wir müssen unsere probleme und ihre
lösungen selbst in die hand nehmen und
unsere geschichte selbst schreiben
paul kagame ist der präsident woran das
in einem anderen video haben wir euch
über die guten und schlechten züge
dieses mannes erzählt sein großes
vorbild ist singapur
man kann sich also vorstellen dass er
kein großer fan von demokratie und
menschenrechten ist aber aus
ökonomischer sicht ist ein vorreiter des
afrikanischen wirtschaftswunders
geworden nun ist es also so dass kagame
nicht nur ruander regiert sondern auch
präsident der afrikanischen union ist
diese organisation wurde im jahre 2001
auf anregung der europäischen union
gegründet
ihr großer traum ist es africa in einem
binnenmarkt zu verwandeln
genau wie europa und bis jetzt scheint
es so als ob sie ihr ziel erreichen will
afrikas freihandelszone tritt mit der
ratifizierung durch gambia und kraft ja
mein leben zuschauer hier kommt das
schon erwähnte cftr ins spiel das
freihandelsabkommen afrika ist
letztendlich besteht ihr ziel in einer
gemeinsamen währung für den ganzen
kontinent etwas ähnliches wie der euro
aber in afrika
wir müssen vielleicht noch 15 bis 20
jahre warten um zeugen dieser
währungsunion werden zu können aber sie
geben sich jetzt schon will
[Musik]
aber okay stimmt jetzt bitte nicht
gleich alle die jubel gesänge an
denn nicht alles hier ist eitel
sonnenschein der teufel steckt auch hier
im detail hier müssten nämlich verstehen
das ist auf der welt zum einen
freihandelsabkommen gibt und zum anderen
freihandelsabkommen ein beispiel für das
letztere wäre der mercosur der mercosur
wurde gegründet um eine freihandelszone
in südamerika zu schaffen hat das
funktioniert die antwort lautet klar
nein die länder die dieses dokument
unterzeichnet haben waren nicht bereit
genug von ihrer souveränität aufzugeben
niemand war bereit die zölle
abzuschaffen und seine einheimischen
unternehmen mit ausländischen
unternehmen konkurrieren zu lassen der
mercosur vertrag ist voll von ausnahmen
ja man kann dort eine menge netter worte
lesen aber wenn man sich die realität
ansieht stellt man fest dass der handel
zwischen seinen mitgliedern nicht
wirklich zugenommen hat etwas ähnliches
könnte auch der afrikanischen
freihandelszone drohen zum beispiel sind
die wichtigsten afrikanischen
volkswirtschaften südafrika und nigeria
keine besonders großen fans dieses
vertrags südafrika hat in letzter minute
unterzeichnet aber nigeria
naja nigeria hat folgendes gesagt
[Musik]
ich lasse nicht zu dass nigeria zur
müllhalde wird muhammadu buhari
präsident von nigeria im grunde genommen
zögern viele regierungen damit die
kontrolle über ihre bereits bestehenden
kleinen industrien abzugeben außerdem
bestehen ihre haupteinnahmen musste ich
eben auch den zöllen diese einstreichen
vergesst nicht dass es in einem land wie
nigeria keinen großen und regulierten
arbeitsmarkt gibt so dass es schwierig
ist einkommenssteuer solche in den
meisten stellen finanzieren sich
afrikanische regierungen aus der
einzigen verlässlichen quelle die sie
kontrollieren können dem außenhandel
aber das ist noch nicht alles
dieser cfk vertrag weg nämlich ebenso
viele zweifel die hoffnung normalerweise
dauert es eigentlich jahrzehnte um einen
solchen vertrag auszuhandeln
dieser hier wurde jedoch in nur vier
jahren durchgezogen und aufgrund des
starken wunsch ist so viele länder wie
möglich einzubeziehen wurden viele dinge
am verhandlungstisch ganz einfach
ausgelassen
das abschlussdokument ist vage und
allgemein gehalten es liegt weder klarer
wettbewerbsregeln fest noch rechte für
investoren oder norm zum schutz
geistigen eigentums es gibt keine liste
welche waren frei gehandelt werden
können und welche geschützt sind
theoretisch haben sich die
unterzeichnerstaaten verpflichtet ihre
zölle für 90 prozent der produkte im
nächsten jahrzehnt abzuschaffen aber die
regierung können die wichtigsten blüte
in den verbleibenden zehn prozent
aufnehmen wenn sie also nur den handel
mit jenen waren liberalisieren die sie
nicht wirklich verkaufen dann haben sie
keinen wirklichen freihandel aber wartet
eine sekunde
denn es gibt noch viel mehr probleme
natürlich wäre die cfk eine wunderbare
möglichkeit um das entstehen neuer
wirtschaftszweige zu fördern aber bis
jetzt ist afrika stark von der
landwirtschaft abhängig und was denken
die afrikanischen bauern darüber nun
viele von ihnen sind nicht gerade
glücklich schmuggler profitieren werden
die guerrilla versucht ausländischen
reis aus dem land zu halten in diesem
fall hat nigeria angst vor dem
benachbarten berlin bin ist zu einem
grossen importeur von thailändischen
preis geworden
offenbar ist thailändischer reis und
hoher qualität und erschwinglich falls
sich nigeria und plötzlich dem handel
mit berlin eröffnet könnte es für die
heimischen reisproduzenten schwierig
werden und hier kommt das große dilemma
ins spiel
sollen wir die landwirtschaft die wir
bereits haben im tausch gegen neue
industrien aufs spiel setzen oder lassen
wir besser alles so wie es ist
das ist die eigentliche debatte um die
sich alles dreht
nach angaben der vereinten nationen
konnte in afrikanische handel bis zum
jahr 2022 innerhalb von drei jahren um
ganze 52 prozent wachsen wenn das cfk
sich so entwickelt wie es geplant war
aber wenn die mitgliedsländer auf immer
neue ausnahmen bestehen und sich
gegenseitig misstrauen könnte das
abkommen natürlich zu einer art mercosur
verkommen mit anderen worten unsere
freunde von terror an tischen motorrad
firma werden weiterhin darauf angewiesen
absatzmärkte außerhalb afrikas
erschließen zu müssen und denkt dran
dass es ohne absatzmärkte überhaupt
keinen industrie gegen die nächste frage
geht also an euch glaubt ihr dass die
csd ahl in eine richtung wie die
europäische union gehen wird oder wird
sie eher in richtung merkur suhr
abdriften soll nigeria eigentlich
beitreten werden der zeuge der
industrialisierung des afrikanischen
kontinents bitte schreibt eure antworten
in den kommentarbereich jede woche sonst
endlich sind wir frische informative
videos für euch wenn ihr also keines
dieser aktuellen updates verpassen wollt
abonniert bitte visual politik und
drückt auch auf die klingel taste um
immer benachrichtigt zu werden und wenn
euch dieses video gefallen hat dann geht
uns einen daumen hoch
machs gut bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]